switching topics though off of Donald
Trump let's get into something a little
more meaningful right well according to
new polls 70% of Republican voters here
in the United States vast majority 70%
actually support the idea put forward
last week by senator Bernie Sanders and
Representative Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
to cap interest rates for credit cards
and payday lenders at fifteen percent
seventy percent of Republicans love this
idea put forward by these Democratic
socialists the reason I love this story
is because right now you have certain
Democratic presidential candidates named
Joe Biden who are telling us that we
can't move too far to the left that
you're going to scare off the moderate
Republicans you're not gonna get any
Republicans to your side pushing these
far left crazy anti corporate ideas
that's what the establishment tells us
that's what the conventional wisdom in
DC tries to tell us but it turns out
that time after time in poll after poll
Republicans actually really love these
socialist ideas and it's not just the
capping of the credit card interest
rates which as of last week we're at of
almost 22 percent average people with
good credit are still paying more than
15% on credit cards people with very
poor or no credit who have to go to
payday lenders you're talking about
dozens upon dozens of percentage points
in interest a 30 40 50 or more in
interest on those just because they had
no credit they get trapped in these
endless debt cycles for this nine
billion dollar industry in fact that
nine billion dollars they make is only
off the interest each year and they're
doing better than ever because Trump has
gutted the CFPB and now they're not
regulating these people like they had
been towards the end of the Obama
administration so they're back the
predatory payday lenders are back and
they're screwing over Americans
and 70% of Republicans understand that
just like 70% of Republicans understand
that credit card companies are doing the
exact same thing but it's not just
capping the interest rates here they
support Medicare for all they support a
$15 minimum wage they support getting
money out of politics and overturning
Citizens United
they support taking action on climate
change they support renewable energy
they support debt free or free college
they support all of these things that
have been trashed as far left socialist
ideas now to throw a wrench in the works
there's another poll from Gallup that
says that only 40% of Americans say that
socialism would be good for the United
States fifty-one percent say that it
would be bad but the flaw with this
Gallup poll is that it's straight up
just asking people with socialism be a
good thing or a bad thing for the United
States once you start breaking that down
into individual policies that might be
socialism but if you just say hey what
about Medicare fraud do you support that
guess what
overwhelming majority of everybody says
yes I do I think that's a good idea even
if you mentioned afterwards that well
isn't that kind of socialism they'll say
oh well I guess it is but I like it
same thing with Social Security which
also by the way a majority of all
parties support expanding Social
Security we we have socialism in place
in the United States today already
so this Gallup poll that says only 40
percent think it would be a good thing
yeah when you ask a misleading question
when you ask about a word which is
socialism that most people honest to god
couldn't even define then yeah they're
probably gonna say it's bad but once you
start breaking it down into individual
policies once you divorce those policies
from a politician or political party
support for them goes up other polls
have proven that when you attach it to a
political party the support does drop a
little not a ton but it does drop a
little but it shows you that the
American public is hungry for
policy and more importantly they're
hungry for policies that most
Republicans and even some centrist
Democrats would absolutely classify as
socialism we have to take a quick break
we'll be right back with more on the
David Pakman show